so julio reyes with a chance to get his
15th win which would lead the majors one
of those 14 wins came against these
braves won five innings gave up just one
run back in june
on a 2-2 he strikes him out with the
fastball and that has been the biggest
difference as julio's gotten such good
results these last two months
one out nobody on the stretch in the 2-2
breaking ball got him called strike
three so the lair caught watching the
paint dry and there were two down got
the mvp coming up in freddy freeman he
lifts one the other way not deep though
aj [ __ ] crews into the corner to
finish off a one two three first inning
drew smiley has got his work cut out for
him but look the braves won 12 in his
last 13 started including nine on the
road for drew as i've said that
curveball is going to be huge for him
tonight
and smiley pulled a string and struck
him out one gone first inning here's
muncie muncie and all-stars two for his
last 32.
he hits this ball
deep right field so there's back it's
gone
solo set for muncie to open the scoring
number 29 of this season for muncie they
do need this this brings confidence not
only to max muncie but the whole lineup
austin wright has put together a career
campaign for the braves
maria sits him down too
before we're given these track records
of these hot braves hitters and the same
time marias is mowing them down with
three k's over the first four batters
swanson leads all major league
shortstops
and runs batted in with 77 he has 25
home runs
and then a fastball line to left [ __ ]
makes a diving play
aj pollock doing it all for the dodgers
here in the second half we're talking
about how the dodgers overall slumping
offensively but a few standouts and this
is one of them will smith
seventh inning high drive down the line
second solo shot in the first two
innings against smiley
22nd of the year for will smith and his
fourth in his last five games
he has done a nice job getting his hands
inside clearing the hip and getting it
down the line he's not holding foul but
he is getting him over the wall
time for julio to rake again huh still
leads the league in rbis
there he goes
first hit in a month and a half for us
the dodgers right fielder mookie batts
who fly to deep left center field his
first time up mookie betts bobblehead
night tonight crushes this ball a ton
way back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
mom
pelican first for seager is 3-1 to
seeger slice to left-center field that
one's deep that one's gone
fourth home run in three innings
they are seven for eight against that
fastball and now four home runs
he stays in hitters counts this is gonna
continue they have not hit the breaking
ball but they have waited and when
they've gotten a heater that they can
reach they have gotten to it
perfect once through the lineup a very
good and hot lineup
gets up on top of that one turner with a
hot shot that he's ready for great play
by justin turner hawk corner shows to be
just that there alby's the first out of
the fourth
jam shot papa long run from muncie
got it not an easy play
solaire is out number two
two gone for freddie freeman on another
2-2 he swings and misses henries is
perfect through four enemies on the
first four innings without giving up a
hit is 2-2
is grounded a third diving play turner
he
can't pull it out
oh goodness
that close to a tremendous play
muncie who's been so sure-handed over
there this season
can't dig it out the first hit of the
game for atlanta
lake giddy up to get him swinging
strikeout number six
two on two out for rosario rios comes
home with the note two rosario grounds
it gently off the end of the bat to trey
turner and that'll wrap up the top of
the fifth doctors five runs on nine hits
atlanta no runs two hits
on the corner back-to-back breaking
balls and then a festival to ring him up
and jorge saler the better he has taken
a call third strike and popped the first
down down in shallow right field
solaire to right that ball is deep that
ball is
gone out of reach of mookie pets
and the braves spoil the shutout bid on
an opposite field home run from jorge
soler
that is his eighth
as a brave it's now a 5-1 game and
freddie freeman is coming up
swing and a shot by freeman deep into
the night back to back homers for the
braves it's five to two then he gets one
right where freddie lives out in
california
that was a no doubter solaire as you
wonder this one
you knew still
put up zeroes in 12 of the 13 games that
he's pitched in in august you see those
50 strikeouts in 41 and two-thirds
innings
punch right side against the defense but
turkey uses that speed to catch up to
the bounding ball for the first down of
the inning two down top of the seventh
base is empty for adam duvall he's one
for two of the single
then the dodgers three huge games with
san fran as that ball is cracked to deep
center and that one's gonna go
adam duvall has hit the third solo homer
for the braves
now the braves are a bloop and a blast
away the ball flying in la
here comes atlanta with urias out of the
game duvall has hit his 29th five braves
three
and jack peterson will lead off this
inning against corey kenable
back to it peterson rolls it to second
trey turner will thrawn
first one gone
enables one one pitch he runs a swing
and a miss throw goes into center field
but they're going to call solaire out
and send all these back to first
interference on solaire
freeman representing the tyne run two
gone in the eighth inning the payoff
right side
trey turner
[Applause]
luke jackson will go to work in the
eighth inning jack peterson stays in the
game for the braves
on the ground great play at third reilly
slipped as he got to his feet but made a
strong throw for the first out
there to play
riley continues his sizzling work at
third base that's right and takes the
mound for the ninth inning looking for
the save
gets in on him
turner
for the first stop
tyner on the board go ahead run to the
plate in the form of adam duvall
he stuck him out
dropped it over the inside corner two
gone
[Music]
it's a high fly ball to center playable
for bellinger bellinger camped out makes
the catch and the dodgers win it 5-3
[Applause]